first off day of the rake
he hasn't stopped can't stop he hasn't
stopped
he's still coming after us
i can't tell you i had every opportunity
these loose ends is too big of a risk
i have to protect teddy tower i cannot
compromise this mission
can't let the dark lord down i can't
tell him i didn't take the shot why
didn't i take the shot
my only option is to lead them away from
teddy tower
affirmative uh location secure codename
blanca fox
all future communications are to be in
analog form the enemy
is a grease fire and we will be the
bucket of water that puts that fire out
if you're a possession
a bucket of water you don't want to use
that for a grease fire that makes a
grease fire worse
this tape this is why you were chosen
for this mission
we will overcome our most dangerous foe
they
know nothing of the deeper truth that
lies beyond their veil of pseudo-reality
subject has been off the grid for some
time now the brass can no longer be
trusted i just hope it's not too late my
web of informants reaches far beyond the
suits in washington
and the foot soldiers of the
establishment this web
knows no borders and works for no
earthly government we answer only to the
wise ones
both of them and with the thoughts of
one and the speech of the second the two
merge combined and coupled with the
insight of the one that's me
we become the three i have enlisted the
help of normies
my spy were now fully activated
did he say spy jim n word
hold on a second jim are you working for
the ottoman oh whoa whoa is jim edward
been spying this whole
time above normies my spy never
now fully activated it's finally how
they fly
we're getting close the spider is
spreading its wings
spiders don't have wings i don't like
i was scared at first but i don't think
this guy understands basic biology
he seems a bit confused if i'm being
fair
okay
[Music]
damn he got here faster than i was
expecting not ready yet
this'll have to do you won't find me
not with this on you'll never find me
i'm currently still in route to target
eternal boomer
i'm gonna leave this device recording so
dangerous i know i'm close
i can feel it shaking in my bones
like a spider's web vibrating to let the
hunter
know that his prey is near it won't be
long now
time to get serious engaged
i know you're out okay this is just
metal gear solid
it is this is metal gear solid i'm
pretty sure i don't think this
i don't think this guy really i don't
think mr of the rake
had this planned out too much i think
this is i don't think he's really trying
to come after us
all right then go meet up with him fight
him in person nah i'm cool
mr tough guy no thanks i can sense your
presence
i can hear the rustle of the brush
beneath your belly as you attempt
with my guess i can smell you
we're
[Music]
what you think i can't see you just
because you got a couple of leaves stuck
to your body what do you take me for
a noob am i a bush was that a bush
irrelevant you'll never know until it's
too late
i already know you have a knife my
spiders have told me this much
but i wonder how would that close range
attack of yours work against my
strong range style
so you came all the way out here into my
world
and you think the dark lord wouldn't
have taught me how to deal with the long
range
oh a wooden bow that's it is this just a
boss fight for metal yo
that's what it looks like it's what it
looks
but did he ever i'm starting to think
these guys are not on the level
no dark lord says i think that these
guys are
honestly doing the same thing that the
chinese do which is just a show footage
from like top gun
yeah and then be like oh we have a super
secret fighter jet
we have very good looking short man he
fly plane [ __ ]
amazing wait they didn't even it's weird
that they used a volleyball scene
they didn't even edit out the theme song
so it was like
it's like you should have just edited
that out or at least redone the theme
with maybe some wooden flute
lights
[Music]
wait so did we win or did he i don't
know i'm confused you came
all the way out here and you think i'm
not ready
this is so ridiculous all this over fox
i still think this is [ __ ] i think
they're lying i think they're just using
footage from video games to scare us
i i mean you might be right i say bring
it bro
royce is waiting bro no no no no he's
waiting to take you
i [ __ ] not waiting [ __ ] i am not
don't
don't stop bunch of [ __ ]
i'm not go ahead find them no no don't
i am please look take you on no i won't
stop speaking listen to me stop speaking
for me [ __ ] please speaking for me
stop speaking for me i will [ __ ]
you're making this bad for me oh i
thought you were mr tough guy
you thought you would take them on
that's what you're telling me off the
air you were saying how like you
said that day of the rakes throat i
never said that
i never said that he said it like he did
he didn't say it but he implied it
all right look